Tom Holland is about to become the
world's most unlikely actions
[Music]
guys I'm sticking his Tom on Andros come
on now it's not funny anymore
[Music]
the 21 year olds of Tasca starring
spider-man it's not to make the world
excited for a spider-man reboot
nobody knew they rocket when you
consider his background no one would
have expected Hallandale of Hollywood's
biggest action franchises Colin was born
on June 1st 1996 in England he's been
performing in some form since he was a
child
ball and dance school he was spotted by
choreographer Lynne page after two years
of intense training and auditioning he
was ready for his first major role in
2008 starring Billy Elliot the Musical
on London's West End while he initially
played a supporting role he was
eventually cast in the title role where
he received positive reviews and
attention a few years later he would
make the leap headfirst in the film his
first credit was as a voice actor in The
Secret World of Arrietty an animated
film from Japan's famed Studio Ghibli he
provided a voice for the youth pay
version in the film in 2012 start
alongside Ian McGregor and Naomi Watts
in the disaster film The Impossible The
Hollywood Reporter called his
performance in the film astonishingly
good it ordered him awards from the
National Board of Review and the London
Film Critics Circle around that time he
starred in small Indies like edge of
winter and Locke and in TV shows like
Wolf Hall he finally edged his way into
a big-budget role in in the heart of the
sea alongside fellow Marvel hero Chris
Hemsworth Island Shop the ranks fairly
quickly but few could have predicted
he'd get his own franchise so soon in
2015 he was cast as spider-man he beat
out actors such as as a Butterfield and
Charlie Plummer announced not long after
the amazing spider-man reboot series
starring Andrew Garfield fizzled out it
wasn't immediately apparent that the
world needed a brand new spider-man any
of those doubts were put to rest after
Holland cameo and Captain America Civil
where he absolutely stole the show
unlike the past two Spider Man Holland
is much younger and therefore makes a
much more convincing version of teenage
Peter Parker in the lead-up to
homecoming we found other ways to stay
in the spotlight Holland is a trained
dancer in gymnast it shows off his moves
daily to his two million Instagram
followers his years in theatre lends
themselves well for playing a superhero
Holland is slated to star in a
spider-man trilogy and eventually meet
up with the Avengers in 2018 Avengers
and spinach is yours for now you can see
him in spider-man homecoming which comes
out on July 2nd
[Music]